[Music]
foreign
they watching The Press preview a first
look at what is on the front page is
time to see then what's making the
headlines with the political editors of
the guardian and the Sun for bakura and
Harry Cole who will be with us from now
until just before midnight and uh great
to see you both so front pages then let
us take a look at the eye which um
describes the Home Secretary swella
brothman is fighting for her political
life of allegations of inhumane
conditions at migrant facilities and her
handling of emails containing sensitive
security information it's the same story
for the guardian the headline bravaman
increases the refugee rhetoric as
pressure to quit grows alarm at
bravman's immigration rhetoric declares
the times
the Metro Pictures three children being
housed at the manston Migrant Center in
Kent
The Daily Mail quotes the Home Secretary
describing the migrant crisis as out of
control
in other news the telegraph understands
the government will stage a dramatic
U-turn by raising taxes for every person
in the country that's also the top story
for tomorrow's Express
the financial times has a story
concerning the battery company British
Vault and fears of its possible collapse
as the energy crisis continues the star
hears that rooms on the Parliamentary
estate in Westminster often have the
heating set as high as 30 degrees
and the sun reports that Netflix have
contradicted Prince William's wishes by
including his mother's Infamous Panorama
interview in the crown well a reminder
by scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of Taurus newspapers
while you watch us so let's get the
thoughts then of pipakura and Harry Cole
and uh possibly not surprising swella
bravman is dominating many of the front
pages including the guardian and
fighting I guess you'd describe it on
two fronts would you Harry
uh yeah well multiple fronts and
starting their own fires tonight
um as well um quite a story day of
um yeah we've had a crazy couple of
weeks um but to be back in the cabinet
after six days in the sinbin and to
still be the total lightning rod of
almost all the negative news uh today in
in Westminster is a pretty impressive
performance by uh sweller braveman
everyone thought she was going to be
sort of down and out
um and you know Hanging On by a thread
um but this afternoon when she finally
got up onto her feet in the House of
Commons at about five o'clock tonight
but actually you know she gave a pretty
Punchy performance
um wasn't to everyone's cup of tea but
anyone that thought you know she was
gonna roll over and say you know and be
quite meek and apologetic oh no she
doubled down and gave way fairly uh yeah
fairly Punchy um performance where she
basically held her hands up and said yep
you know what the Asylum system in this
this country is a joke it's not working
it's completely failed and you know what
are we going to do about it to which the
opposition we're laughing um pointing
out that the toys have actually been in
power for quite a long time now but uh
you know the garden
yeah well exactly the guardian and other
newspapers
um you know have her defenses this is
about the uh situation in Kent with
refugees being housed for a long time in
overcrowded conditions in a place which
is only meant to be open for them for 24
hours until they're shipped elsewhere so
did she block hotels she says she did
not she did not hold up anything that
happened there but indeed the local MP
atori disagrees with her Pippa
yes sir Roger Gale who visited the
Center yesterday suggested that four
weeks ago before she took over as Home
Secretary the processing center and it
is just that people who arrive in the UK
are taking the effort to get their
Biometrics taken us on before they moved
on elsewhere
um but because there's currently now
nowhere to be moved on because
apparently uh Sarah Brotherman took the
decision that no more hotels should be
procured
um no more hotel rooms should be
procured for them the there's been this
huge backlog so the processing center
can take about 1600 people it currently
has about 4 000 people in it it's not
designed to have families or children
staying there for any length of time
there's people sort of camped up in
tents
um outside uh obviously the facilities
are under under huge pressure and
suggestion is that the staff aren't well
equipped enough to be able to deal with
this sort of situation and Roger Gale is
amongst those who are pointing to think
of agreement
saying that actually it was pretty
pretty well functioning center before
she took over and change the um you know
the situation with onward onward
movement
um and and therefore is blooming heart
she quite clearly today Harry is
absolutely right she kind of sort of
doubled down on on the actions that
she's taken
um she also revamped up the rhetoric
which didn't go down well in all
quarters including with her own party
well it might appeal to some on the
right
um immigration in general as an issues
obviously
um a real sort of political Hot Potato
uh it also angered many on the left and
some and some of her own MPS who felt
that she was insensitive for talking
about an invasion on the south coast
that was of course a reference to the 40
000 people coming here now I think this
I think it's important just to
differentiate between the fact that this
is a processing center and sort of the
immigration issue more broadly which
obviously is very difficult for anybody
to deal with
um and you know Solutions have been
suggested wind-ranging as they are I
haven't yet 12 years old managed to
manage to amount to sort of a coming
those numbers coming down
um it'd be interesting to see whether
issues select managed us as well or
indeed
as the Home Secretary to try who tries
to do that on his behalf yes while you
were talking we we had a look at the
Metro and welcome to the UK a picture
there are some of the children held at
the manston processing center after
report by hm hm and Specter of prison
said that there were no beds for people
no fresh air
um in some places toilet doors weren't
allowed to close which they found
inexplicable and exhausted detainees
were simply sleeping on the floor of
this converted military Center but if we
look at the eye Harry cabinet anger as
bravman fights for her political life
um the quote in their sentences
um in in that front page some cabinet
ministers privately question whether
brothman is up to the job now who's
saying that and and what is the clamor
for for her to well I don't know what
she'd do this time
uh it's a tricky one look it's obviously
a it is a poison chalice put it lightly
this has been an issue that's affecting
um you know affected multiple home
secretaries
um not pretty Patel was quite forthright
in her views but eventually you know
talked to very very very good game but
actually you know these numbers have
been ticking up each year the the
government have been empowered there's
nothing that really that what is the
option what is the solution the argument
Braverman is making is actually 2.2
billion pounds is a phenomenal amount of
money at a time we're about to go
through a fiscal tightening 150 pounds a
night minimum for these hotel rooms you
know they are running out of stock in
terms of two star three-star one-star
hotels in the country we're now into
four-star hotels you know photos are
going to think you know paying 600
pounds a night for to for this is it is
absurd and it is so the problem is
though the Braven is actually if you you
know she just needs to sort of come out
and be a little bit I think more candid
and honest about the decisions he's made
rather than trying to say oh actually no
I'm not changing anything it's carrying
on but we need to we need to rip it all
up so she's in a bit of a mess I think a
more slightly more tactful and perhaps
um
slightly more delicate way of of putting
uh some of the things she said today but
the system is clearly understandable
she's I'm you know she's totally right
to say where if a thousand people arrive
each day where where are you going to
put them Circo are one of the private
contractors is looking at all sorts of
different schemes now to get old Care
Homes old schools possibly even pop-up
Marquees and Tents
um getting private landlords to rent out
their homes to to the home office to to
house migrants and you just think this
is politically and economically
unsustainable so something has to give
the problem is the second anyone says we
need to do something about this all hell
breaks loose then there's a big
screaming match
well the Daily Mail picks up on that
point saying the Home Secretary said it
was almost impossible to house all
arrivals and it was time to stop
pretending that everyone making the
crossing to Britain was a refugee in
distress we heard that clearly but they
also go on to pick up on what I would
deemed to be the other part that she's
fighting on which is the breaking of the
ministerial code the stuff that she
resigned about under Liz truss's
leadership and a letter that she wrote
today to the chair of the home Affairs
Select Committee in which she outlined
six other occasions when she had emailed
herself government information now this
she implied was sort of an aid Memoir
for meetings and interviews that she was
doing a little bit like using a notebook
um does the letter she wrote explaining
what happened the first time and these
subsequent times get her off the hook on
that score pepper
really I mean it kind of raises more
questions actually as to why she thought
it was okay even if as she says that uh
none of these six emails can concern
National Security or intelligence agency
matters other sort of sensitive matters
why they hate Home Secretary was um was
using her private her private email
account and private phone to contact
people
um in the case of obviously laterally
the one that she she sacked over um
somebody who outside outside the home
office
um and there's been a whole load of
questions which have been raised today
uh you know the timings she claimed
initially in that resignation letter to
Liz trust that she had alerted
um her civil servants pretty quickly
urgently actually we found out today
that we had this this sort of time scale
of being of alerted of she herself was
alerted to the mistake at 10 am and
didn't let her private secretary know
until about three hours later and
actually the cabin office number 10
found out first the chief whip basically
told her that she needed to um inform
her officials but she hadn't really done
so by that point and then there's also
this point about the day that she and
Harris reported this I've reported this
as well the day that she went uh number
10 was briefing out that one of the
reasons she went was because the the
details of this written ministerial
statement that was leaked
um was it was potentially Market moving
because it obviously was about
immigration and the potential that that
has on on the obr forecasts and then
today we were told by number 10 that
actually wasn't Market moving now you
know which is it who was telling the
truth there so I think the letter and
all sort of like you know the security
implications around it have raised some
more questions about her and also
frankly amazing questions about Rishi
sinak's judgment because he reappointed
just six days after she was sacked for
the security breach we all know that was
because some deal was struck in order to
get her to support him in the Tory
leadership contest and get him over the
line problem is is that's put him in a
difficult position now she is sort of
like the standard bearer of the right if
you like the ERG in his cabinet he wants
to keep the party United if he comes
under great pressure to to set to get
rid of her if there's more Revelations
for example in the weeks ahead it'd be
very difficult for him squaring that
with the right of his party so you know
it's not just about the political sense
of his sensitivities around immigration
which are on their own are pretty major
issue it's also about sort of the
political Fallout and the sort of impact
yes and and also from um the
conservative MPS including Andrew Percy
whose staff member had accidentally
received this document that Liz truss
had sent erroneously
um and you know in this letter that she
wrote
um included the the email from Mr Percy
MP saying I'm really not sure that
government documents should be being
shared with members of your former
campaign team via email simply asking my
team to delete this email and ignore it
is not an acceptable response to what
appears on the face of it to be a
potentially serious breach of security I
mean frustrations there even on the day
of this Harry
yeah I think the problem that sort of
braveman's got I think she probably will
has probably done enough to sort of get
all the get it all out there and and
give a clear enough explanation it's
clearly got past her sort of permanent
secretary who's sort of signed this
letter off
um the problem is well it fundamentally
comes down to is why was she gonna write
this ministerial statement that she
leaked or why was why was Liz trust
making it right this ministerial
statement it was to try and affect and
change the obr growth forecast now if
the contents of a written ministerial
statement would change the forecast of
the obr the office of budget
responsibility by its very nature that
is Market sensitive information because
you're literally trying to move a
regulator into saying the markets are
going to like this so therefore
um therefore it's a good thing so I
can't don't really understand how she's
in any position to say it's not Market
sensitive but but there we go but
pippa's right this is all about politics
this was a nakedly political act to a
point to celebrate women and we've seen
the the consequences of that at the
dispatch box today it was quite ironic
that it came less than 24 hours the
British sunac stood on the steps of
Downing Street saying I'm above politics
so I'm going to put the country first
um for a man who spent a year agitating
to get that job and now got it and then
kind of deal with its First Act yeah it
does it does jar a bit okay we'll see
where that uh that heads uh if I can put
it that way plenty was still to come
though including contrary what the
government promised a few weeks ago tax
increases could soon be on the way for
everyone back with that adjustment
foreign
[Music]
with me once again Pippa crew and Harry
Cole welcome back to both of you
um so let's go to the Daily Telegraph
paper shall we uh sweeping tax Rises for
who exactly what does the paper say
well it suggests this is obviously a
treasury briefing
um that has come out today and has gone
to uh what I would describe as the
friendly newspapers although one
government advisor says to me that
there's no such thing as friendlies
anymore
um which I think
seeing some of the fun pages that
they've put up with in in recent in
recent uh days and weeks anyway sorry
back to the point um as we all know
there's a there's a very big black hole
in the public finances
um in the Public Finance has been a
pretty precarious position anyway and
then that mini budget made things worse
um and
um we uh and since Jeremy Hunt took over
as Chancellor uh and Rishi sinak made it
back to number 10 they've obviously
ripped it up started again pushed back
the deliver the date for the budget by a
couple of weeks till to the middle of
next month Midland November
um and uh are going through a whole
series of ways in which they can plug
that gap which Telegraph another suggest
is about 50 billion pounds now it's no
surprise that uh Public Public Service
cups are on the agenda
um and or indeed that tax Rises are on
the agenda and the suggestion the
telegraph is that you're going to look
at pretty much half of that black hole
being filled by tax cuts and half of it
being filled by um by cuts to public
spending
um obviously that raises quite a lot of
problems quite a lot of issues
politically it's going to be very
difficult and this to me is very much a
way of the treasury of the government
trying to uh really sort of roll the
pitch if you like which as we all know
didn't happen uh with quite catastrophic
consequences at the at the last mini
budget you're all the pitch to warn
people that there will be tough tough
tough times ahead and on the public
sector spending part of that obviously
departments many departments feel that
they've really cut the burner ready
after 10 years of 12 Years of of
austerity
um public sector pay is a particular
issue some suggestion that could only go
up by sort of by a couple of percent
when obviously inflation is
substantially higher than that but let
me bring in we've got only a minute left
I want to get Harry's view on this one
as well
um you know a rough road ahead exactly
um off of it on tax Rises half of it on
spending cuts you know both feel ugly to
people don't they
I mean I watch this stuff um you know
day in day out as a job and I've I feel
like I've got whiplash you know I can
remember old enough to remember in July
when Reggie sunac and Jeremy Hunt were
all saying let's cut Corporation attack
let's go Jeremy Helm was saying that's
called corporation tax Richie sunac was
unveiling his path to three bends off of
uh income tax over the next three years
uh Lewis trust obviously um was the one
that got the pool lever and it turned
out to be a trapdoor
um I do suspect there's probably a
little bit of of setting the scene here